What defines you?
There’s nothing I wouldn’t do
for my daughter.
I've loved Laura Dave's book,
The Last Thing He Told Me,
from the get-go.
There's an engine under it that just
makes you want to keep reading.
The show has that same kind of energy.
The series is really asking the question,
"Can we ever really know
the person we love?"
And what we're willing to do
for our children.
Hey, it’s Owen.
Leave a message.
The Last Thing He Told Me
is, above all else, a love story.
Hannah Hall loves Owen Michaels.
Hannah fell in love later in life.
She feels like there's a oneness
that she has with her husband.
They've just begun their life together.
The big challenge for the relationship
is that he has a teenage daughter.
I’ll wait out front.
And her relationship with Hannah
is as bad as you can get,
when suddenly one day
Owen doesn't come home.
Mr. Michaels asked me
to give this to you.
I just spoke to my source
at the U.S. Attorney's office, Hann.
Owen’s a material witness.
They'll likely make him
a subject of the investigation.
Where is he, Hannah?
I don't know.
Owen’s disappearance sets in motion
these two women,
who are virtual strangers,
trying to figure out
what happened to the person
they both love more
than anyone in the world.
You're not going to school tomorrow.
I’m not?
I have a new plan.
She very, very quickly has to learn
what it means to care for this daughter.
Throughout the show, we get to see
Bailey understanding how to have a mother
and Hannah understanding how to be one.
He said he'd always be there.
I don't know what's happening here,
but I do know your dad loves you.
D mark.
And, action!
The Last Thing He Told Me, as I read it,
you could see it play out in front of you.
And I've loved being part of
this thrilling mystery.
The role of Hannah is that balance
between tough and vulnerable,
and Jen Garner, she's just extraordinary.
She has been able to really tap into
Hannah's deep strength.
Her trust in who Owen is as a person
is what keeps driving them
to solve this mystery
and trust her instincts
that there's something more to the story.
I may not know why your father did
what he did, but I know who he is.
Watching Jen and Angourie together,
the extraordinary talent
that they have as actresses,
it's just been such a gift.
And then you have Nikolaj.
He is incredible.
Owen Michaels is not who you think he is.
Why are you making him sound like
some sort of criminal mastermind?
You just get such a range of colors,
and you get the hints of this darker past.
Even in his charm.
He lied to me about everything.
I want to know the truth!
I'm telling you, we’ll find it.
The tension between the mystery
and the relationships is really unique.
You feel like, "Oh, this is a mystery.
Oh, this is a thriller."
But really, it's a story about parenting
and about motherhood.
Together, they have to find the truth,
and the mystery is incredible
as it unfolds.
You're following these characters
in a very intense
emotional point in their lives,
and it makes for a great dramatic show
that will keep audiences
on the edge of their seat.
You said that people
don't run for no reason.
Now the FBI is threatening me.
Whatever this is, you want no part of it.